- Today we're trying Canadian taters.
- Potato chips.
(funk bass music)
- They supposed to be
like, epic chips, I heard.
- There better be a poutine chip.
- I want a maple syrup flavored chip.
- Let's do this.
- Montreal Smoked Meat?
(speaking in foreign language)
- They're very vague
about what type of meat.
- It looks like a roast beef sandwich.
- Oooh, it smells like Arby's.
- Yeah, oh, it does!
- It's so meaty!
- It has a little bit of spiciness to it.
My mouth is burning.
- I don't know what you're talking about.
- What?
- They've nailed it, but I don't like it.
- You know, like, they
can put, meals in a chip.
- Just like Willy Wonka.
- Yeah.
- Cowboy BBQ Beans!
- I love BBQ beans!
- Were there cowboys in Canada?
- This is the Western Canada finalist,
which makes a lot of sense.
- I see a--
- [Woman] I started.
I started, I got so excited.
- They taste like the syrup that's
at the bottom of a can of beans.
- Are you tasting the beans at all?
- [Woman] Yeah!
- Oh, I'm into these.
- Get me these in every
7-11 across America.
- Ah, scalloped potatoes.
- What does P.E.I. mean?
- Private Investigator Food?
- P.E.I. is Prince Edward Island.
- Atlantic Canada, which is
like Saskatchewan, right?
- This tastes like some buttery goodness,
like some Paula Deen (censor bleep).
- It literally just tastes like
cheddar and sour cream chips.
- Yeah, I'm a fan, I'm
a supporter of these.
- Butter Chicken
(speaks in foreign language)
- This is from Ontario!
- This is how you know there are a lot
of Indian people who live in Ontario.
- It kind of tastes like
I'm eating just cumin.
- It tastes like sauce?
- I think it has a crab vibe.
- It's the Canadian style of Indian,
which is just not spicy at all.
- I'm kind of into those.
- Got to be the Baked Bean because,
when else have I tried that?
- [Man] I loved--
- That's the best.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Okay, so you'll take
these home with you then?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll take these.
- [Man] And then I'll take,
I'm going to take the beans.
- Yeah, how do we get these in America?
I'm going to drop every other cause
I care about, and only work toward
getting these chips in America.